let's go next to Stephen from Tacoma
Stephen welcome to the program what's
going on today
uh yes sir can you hear me yes
um yes I wanted to talk about
um uh the thing around RFK Jr right now
and uh how he's doing so well in the
polls right now and um how much of that
do you think is um not really his
policies but mainly his right name
recognition as a Kennedy I think that
the main Rec name recognition is a part
of it
um but also uh it his I've seen some
breakdowns and his support seems to have
spiked in particular actually among
Republicans interestingly enough and
um the other thing is if you go back and
look at look at his polling I have it on
the screen in front of me in early May
and late April let me let me say it more
chronologically in late April early May
there are a bunch of polls that have RFK
around 20 percent like there's an
Emerson poll that had him at 21 a fox
poll that had him at 19 a CNN poll at
20. now he rarely even hits 15. like
there's one poll that has him at 17 but
now he's as low as eight and typically
in the low to mid teens he overall RFK
actually seems to have lower polling
support today than he did several months
ago so I don't know I don't really make
much of it one way or the other I think
that it's potentially a spoiler campaign
I think there's a lot of Mag of people
that like it because it's chaotic and it
might hurt Joe Biden but you know I've
talked about it I I feel like it's I've
struggled Stephen to find the right
amount to talk about RFK when I don't
talk about and people say I'm ignoring
him because I'm scared when I do talk
about him people write to me say David
this guy's got no shot and he's cuckoo
why are you even talking about him you
know if you're polling 14 in the
Democratic primary I think it makes
sense that I talk about you a little bit
but I don't find the entire thing super
impressive
okay yeah because I figured that a lot
of his name right a lot of his name
recognition was helping him in the polls
and yeah whatever wait the Kennedy name
still has but it might I think for I
think for really anybody under maybe the
age of 40 that's kind of a historical
name that's just kind of my two cents on
it but as I can see some of the polls
he's starting to go down people are
starting to notice that he's getting
more support from like Steve Bannon and
all the mega people and people are
starting to figure out they're looking
beyond the Kennedy name and realizing oh
wait this guy is he's he's a um I'm not
going to say the term but he's trying to
mess up the potential primary or
potential uh Biden vote yeah I mean
listen we'll see where it goes but my
money is that it doesn't have a lot of
oxygen left to grab
yeah I figured that too all right all
right thank you David all right thank
you very much there's Stephen from
Tacoma very very important uh subject
matter being discussed in General on
today's program and I appreciate that